so twitter is down and people are
talking about it and it kind of brought
up a thing that I've been thinking about
quite a bit lately which is that people
are underrated and human interaction is
underrated and the value of it is so
much greater than most people think and
that's fascinating to me it's
fascinating to me that people don't know
what to do right now because they can't
communicate on Twitter and they're
jumping the friend feed and Facebook and
other things of that nature but what I
want to talk to you about is global
business I think it's a massive
underrated thing to not be communicating
when people face to face and I see a
decline in it and it's really
interesting to me because don't forget
the people that make every business
decision are people not the robots not
yet and so there's a lot in there guys
the fact of the matter is this if you
are not allocating at least one to two
hours a day to do breakfast lunch dinner
drinks with people that you want to do
business with then you're leaving a
massive opportunity absolutely even go
as far as saying this is grossly
negligent to not allocate 90 minutes a
day for human interaction business it's
something that is massively successful
for me now I can be full of crab and
wrong and that probably is very possible
but I've seen so much success and
actually knowing somebody so when you
pick a ping on aim or admo where you
Facebook wall that or whatever you're
going to do in the future hologram down
when you close your eyes yo Pete what's
up you know whenever you're going to do
it's still going to come down to Pete
it's still going to come down to
somebody that you know better because
you actually spent some physical time a
little hug a little bit handshake that
stuff is the difference maker it's it's
almost funny that it's not what you know
to you know is probably even greater
than ever it's not what you know it's
not who you know
it's how much time you actually spend
face-to-face with who you know give that
some thought bringing into your
repertoire add it to the way you do
business and let me know in three months
what you've seen and how it's affected
your business I have a feeling you'll be
happy with me I wish you the best I hope
your family's well and i'll talk to you
soon